hello everyone Rob Greenfield here in
the garden and today I'm going to share
my tips for beginner gardeners so if you
are out there feeling like you have a
black thumb feeling like whatever you
plant dies and you are dreaming of
having a green thumb dreaming of growing
and abundance of food and having that
fresh food on your table to eat then
this is the video for you I actually
feel like I'm in a really good position
to be able to share these tips with you
and the reason why is it's not that long
ago that I was a complete rookie
gardener myself go back just three years
ago and I had grown very little food and
then I launched into a year-long project
of attempting to and successfully
growing and foraging everything that I
ate for an entire year and during that
year I grew over a hundred different
foods in my garden so I quickly went
from a beginner who had grown very
little to a pretty experienced gardener
who has spent hundreds of hours in my
garden in other people's gardens both in
the United States and in other parts of
the world so I'm in a place where I can
still remember the nights of frantic
searching online and calling friends and
seeds not sprouting and plants dying and
just that that fear to now having the
confidence and really being way beyond
that beginner stage so that's why I'm
really excited to be able to share this
advice with you from a recent beginner
to and now pretty decent gardener so my
first tip is a really simple one and
that is to start small a lot of people
have this dream of turning their whole
yard into a garden and growing an
incredible amount of food that is a
wonderful dream to have I completely
support it but what a lot of people miss
out on is the fact that it doesn't
happen overnight that you go from having
very little gardening skills to all of a
sudden this paradise achill garden
everybody has to start somewhere and for
a lot of us who don't have gardening in
our background our parents didn't garden
where we're starting kind of from
scratch as adults starting small is one
of my absolute key places for beginner
gardener so that could be in a small
raised bed in your front yard
it could mean you know some plants on
your balcony or your windowsill don't
put yourself down for any amount of food
that you grow any amount of food you
grow is a really positive step forward
so start small and each
season you can add on more and more and
more and this will also build your
confidence one step at a time if you
start with way more than you could
possibly handle often it gets away from
you you become overwhelmed and then you
just kind of lose it all so if that's
the case for you and you don't think you
can go big right away absolutely start
small now if you have so much free time
and you really think this is what you
want to do
I'm not discouraging you from going big
but definitely one of my number one tips
is start small if you feel like that is
what is needed for you at the time next
up is keep it local really try to seek
out the local resources the truth is is
that the gardening knowledge is almost
everywhere it's often that we pass it up
we don't realize that anybody gardens in
our area cuz we're not looking for it
and we don't realize it but everywhere
around the country and around the world
there are local resources that really
know that area well so seek out local
nurseries local seed companies local
gardeners if you're driving around your
neighborhood then you see a garden in
someone's front yard knock on that door
and say hello and talk to them a really
great way to go local is community
gardens join a community garden so that
you can learn what plants are growing
well there get support from them
another thing is local classes if you
can find classes that are in your area
that's a great way to get the knowledge
that is based on your area and then
books as well check out your local
library often they will have books that
are based on your region or your state
for example when I was in Florida I got
Robert Bowden's book which was Florida
fruit and vegetable gardening so it was
geared exactly towards my area and
leaves out so much of the information
that I didn't need it focuses on the
information that you need keeping as
local as you possibly can and then that
moves into the next one and they're
pretty much tied together and that is
garden as a community garden together
there's no reason to do this alone if
you are at home alone doing this all by
yourself and all you're doing is looking
on the internet you know Facebook groups
and things like that watching YouTube
videos sure those things are helpful but
it's easy to feel you know really
overwhelmed and unempowered when it's
all by yourself so get involved with
others when I had my garden in my front
yard I'd have people drive by and I
would see them stop and look and I would
encourage them to stop by one time I
even had someone knock on my door and he
very timidly said I know this is awkward
but I've been dreaming of starting to
grow food with my kids I just had to
knock on the door and ask and I I walked
him throughout my garden send him home
with a bunch of food and gardeners love
that gardeners love to share their time
and their knowledge so get involved with
local people joining a community garden
is one of the simplest easiest ways to
do that if you can another thing you can
do is volunteer at local organic farms
there's a website called whooping
worldwide opportunities on organic farms
it's WWF dotnet and that's a great way
to just immerse in local food growing
and you can also travel and do it as
well so there is no need to do it alone
the resources are out there that
knowledge is out there that community is
out there gardeners welcome people in so
don't do it alone
do it with community now keeping on that
theme of local but moving into actual
plants moving into the planting where do
you source your seeds and your plants
for me it's all about local varieties so
seeking out local seed companies and
local nurseries that have been growing
these plants in your region for years or
even decades how that works is if the
plant is designed for that area it
already knows the insects that are going
to attack it it already knows the
weather patterns this is a plant that is
designed to grow in that area so if you
can buy your seeds from local seed
companies that produce them in your area
as well as nurseries this drastically
increases your chance of success whereas
going to the big-box stores and buying
the plants that have been shipped from
who knows how far away from some
of centralized distribution center those
plants might not be designed for your
area for example where I did a lot of my
gardening in Florida big fat juicy
tomatoes like beefsteak tomatoes don't
do well there what does really well is
the small Everglades tomato and with the
Everglades tomato a person with a black
thumb boom green thumb and tomatoes and
incredible amounts but if you're trying
to grow those big ones that are not
adapted to that area
black them dies molds gets tomato blight
and you don't get anything and you you
know walk away feeling like a failure
so seeking out your local seed companies
and your local nurseries is a huge step
in the right direction when a lot of
people start planning their garden and
they start planning what they want to
plant what they do is they think about
what their favorite foods are and they
even walk down the grocery store aisles
and think okay these are my favorite
things to eat so this is what I'm going
to plant and sure that can be beneficial
but here's the downside of that if
you're doing that most of our grocery
stores are based on globalization where
food is shipped in from all different
regions where it does really well in
this area and not well in that area and
if you do it that way you'll often end
up planting things that just aren't
gonna do well in your area so I think
the best thing to do is instead of going
to the grocery store and asking what you
like to eat talk to people in your
community ask them what grows so
ridiculously well that you can't even
kill it what grows so well that it
becomes a problem because there's so
much of it and plant those things for
example here in this garden that I'm in
mint is taking over like crazy and I
just made a video about easy plants to
start growing this is one of them plant
what has the fewest pests what grows
really easily and then once you've
mastered those easier plants then you
can start to get into the more difficult
ones maybe you love blueberries but they
grow in acidic soil
so if you don't have a civics oil you
don't want to start there but once you
get more experience then you can work
with changing the pH of your soil that's
a little bit more advanced gardening so
again with the grocery store we've
become disconnected with the seasons
being able to get most things at any
time throughout the year but one of the
absolute most important things is to
plant the right things at the right time
if you try to plant tomatoes early on in
the spring while it's still very cold
and the soil temperature is really low
you're gonna have our time because in
colder climates they like heat the same
goes for basil that's gonna be later on
early things for example kale can be
started earlier and actually in very hot
places it doesn't do well in the peak
heat because it likes the colder
temperatures
so it's really important to plant the
right things at the right time and you
don't have to figure out each individual
plant what you have to do is simply find
a planting schedule you can check at
local universities often their Extension
Program will have a planting schedule
some community gardens will have them
and you can also just go online and
search for for example if you live in
New York New York planting schedule and
this will help you to plant the right
things at the right time and by doing
that ensure the success of those plants
as far as the details like how far apart
do you plant each different thing like
tomatoes or kale or arugula and how deep
do you plant the seeds and should you
transplant as in starting from pots in
the greenhouse or in your house or
direct sow the seeds into the ground for
that I recommend following the
instructions on back of the seed packs
that you get and really importantly
getting a book for your area which I
mentioned at the beginning a lot of
these books that are based on your area
they give you those details so you don't
have to seek it out for each individual
one so in this video I'm not going to go
through those details because they're
based on each area instead get a local
book for your region and follow the
instructions from the seed companies
where you buy those seeds there's a lot
of other
details for example sun and water and
soil you could talk about that for hours
and hours and hours but i want to give
just a few tips on that as far as sun
goes for beginner gardeners i generally
recommend full sun now if you're in a
shaded area like i am right now that's
really difficult there's plants that can
grow well in shade but generally most
plants need a lot of sun make sure that
you're not under the shade of a tree or
where your house casts shade for half of
the day so before you plant your garden
keep an eye on that spot and remember
that the Sun changes throughout the year
so planting in full Sun as far as water
one of the basic ways to tell if you're
watering enough is when you grab a
handful of that soil ideally it should
stay in a clump that breaks a little bit
and it's basically the consistency of a
wrung out sponge so watering in the
morning is the best before the heat and
if not the morning then the evening not
in the middle of the day another way to
test if you have enough water as you
stick your finger down into the soil and
if its moist when you get your finger
down to about your second knuckle here
then that's another sign that you have
enough water if it's dry all the way
down it needs to be watered so soil
varies all over the place and how you're
watering whether you're in the desert or
in a very fertile area like Southwest
Wisconsin or in Florida where it's
mostly sand it's going to vary a lot but
those are a few tips with water and
again local resources are key because
they're gonna know your soil and then
another one is healthy soil a lot of
people they only focus on the plants and
when they see problems they think about
the plants but the truth is one of the
most important things is having healthy
living soil so take care of your soil
take very good care of your soil your
soil is your life source to have that
healthy and abundant food my next tip is
to make it convenient now what I mean by
that is putting your garden in a
location where you naturally go if you
put your garden you know a ten minute
walk on the other side of your
property where you can't see it it
easily becomes out of sight out of mind
and it's easy to neglect so put it in an
area where you naturally go every day
maybe your front yard right next to your
front sidewalk where every day you have
to walk past it to get to your car that
way every morning and night you're
naturally drawn to it and the same goes
for water making sure that you have your
water source near your garden ideally
whether that's a long hose or if you
don't have a hose right next to the
spigot where you have your buckets or
your rainwater harvesting designing it
so that it has a you know relative
amount of convenience we'll make it
easier to get out there don't put a
whole bunch of obstacles in the way and
this is really important when when you
are getting started and you're not used
to it and you don't have a habit of
getting into the garden and you have a
habit of just going to the grocery store
it's easy to neglect it when you're just
getting started and you have an
incredible amount of information out
there and it's really hard to choose
which is the right information it's it's
easy to be infiltrated by chemical
mindsets the idea that you know you need
to spray things that every insect should
die that the soil needs these massive
amount of fertilizers but my tip is
don't fall into the chemical mindset in
my year of growing and foraging all of
my food where I grew over a hundred
different foods I never used a single
pesticide not even organic ones and
these pesticides have only existed for a
tiny tiny fraction of all the times that
humans have lived off of the food that
they've grown so you can grow without
all of that without needing to have all
of this money and this upside resources
and be able to grow in an organic in a
sustainable manner
next I want to talk a little bit about
mindset and focusing on a mindset of
abundance rather than scarcity because
when you think in scarcity it often
creates scarcity around you but when you
design in abundance and you think in
abundance that can actually help create
that abundance a really important part
of that is remembering that
in order to have an abundance you have
to have done death is a part of the
gardening experience so don't be afraid
to kill plants in fact when you kill
plants think of that as part of your
lessons part of your learning to
becoming a successful gardening and in
that way it's not a failure it's a part
of the success but even more importantly
remember plants die it's not like
especially annual plants like carrots
and kale and collards and broccoli
all of these only live for a period of
time they have to be harvested and then
they die don't think of death as a
failure think about it as a part of the
cycle of the gardening another thing
that I mentioned just now I mentioned
annuals annuals are plants that
basically you plant every single year
and you harvest and you have to replant
every year perennials are plants that
you plant once and they come back for a
very long time raspberries and
blackberries and blueberries
strawberries fruit trees like apples and
pears and plums nut trees Jerusalem
artichoke rhubarb all of these foods
that come back year after year are
perennials so I recommend working with
perennials as much as you can because
they generally take less work they have
a lot fewer pests they take less
nutrients and they keep on coming back
year after year after year and many
perennials thrive on neglect focusing on
perennials is definitely a big tip that
I would move towards it's it's often
great to start with annuals
for example radishes they produce in 30
days that's one of those easy plants
that I mentioned that can give you that
boost of success and that confidence to
move forward but as you get better and
better
I recommend moving more away from those
annuals and moving more towards the
perennial system so there you have it
those are some of my most important tips
for beginner gardeners there's a lot of
other ones out there but if you just
start with those ones and you remember
to start small start simply maybe start
with just five easy plants that you're
excited about and if you do five the
next year and you do five the next year
within a few years time you can be
growing dozens of different species make
some goals make some of those smaller
goals make some of those bigger goals
and use those smaller goals to chip away
at that ultimate success of you know
your giant front yard just dripping and
oozing with food absolutely everywhere
so I hope that you gained a lot from
this video if you did make sure that you
subscribe if you have friends who are
beginner gardeners that consider
themselves to have a black thumb make
sure to share this video to help them if
you think it would be helpful and if you
want to get this out into the YouTube
world ask questions comment in the
comments below to make sure to give it a
thumbs up as well so I love y'all very
much and I'll see you again in the
garden real soon